s'appelant monsieur georges marchais oui
voilà j'arrive aujourd'hui trois marins
de becker bonjour mais ce marché
mais dites moi qu'est ce que c'est que
ce chien que ben je sais pas c'est un
chien un chien des rues où il est
jacques brialy regarder sociaux ne plus
prier j'ai trouvé devant le faubourg
saint-honoré devant l'elysée avec le
collier
regardez ça ça doit être le chien
giscard et ben voici il a des envies de
revient d'y croire ça doit être ça et
vous savoir alors moi je vous écoute à
europe 1 le matin jeudi à 8h30 les est
tout frais tout rose et la grande forme
alors de richert oui oui et vous est-ce
que vous levez tout ce marché mais moi
j'ai pas de problème jugé un réveil
téléphoner seiu paysan n'a aucune autre
pas vodafone uk andro port louis qui
avons travaillé dans un cagibi et
chasser les taux oui c'est lé top c'est
des gens qui sans qu'ils aient vers
l'intelligence avec l'ennemi mois que
déjà du mal en floride richert est alors
j'ai installé ligne directe chez moi
après paris et kremlin c'est le seul
appareil il ya que l'écouteur droit nuit
et qu'est-ce que vous prenez le matin
pour déjeuner à jeu sucre jamais mon
café je mets juste un peu de sakhaline
oui c'est amusant mais voilà comment son
passé aux vacances le marché mais très
bien derrière le rideau de fer comme
d'habitude tu vas rire kg pour moi il
revient après moi j'ai un avantage est
que je veux aller en union soviétique et
je vais en sortir jus ni juive ni
intellectuel compromise de même à l'air
alors voilà et puis tout s'est très bien
passé à la fête de l'huma nous a pas vus
vous auriez pu venir il y avait de la
place surtout un stand des droits de
l'homme y avait personne et parce en a
vendu 300 tonnes de merguez pour la fête
des travailleurs voient voilà dit quoi
monsieur oui monsieur marc chez moi
quand je vois la télévision jouer un peu
de ton du bager j'ai d'abord je n'ai pas
jamais à la télé
oh j'ai souvent l'occasion de mon plein
dans la télévision et oui comment je
sais que vous faites vous n'êtes plus en
plus d'audience faut que ce soit en
europe et à la tv on voit que vous
partez vite souriait toujours bronzé et
tout un foin de souriau louis près de
lorient qu'on appelle josé lins comme ce
marché des cadres et le souriez paix
quadrille naturel non cadrée celle entre
les actes oui bien sûr j'ai pas que je
ressemble à bouchardeau ma femme
commencerait la dernière fois que j'ai
vu à la tv c'était même la première fois
je le voyais j'ai cru que mon post est
déréglée 50 ans va déboucher chardon se
dit elle va graver les vices et de la
sécurité sociale réforme la régal à
regarder on tombe malade cizek ce marché
oui vous avez quelque chose à nous dire
ben oui j'ai quand même un message à
faire passer d'eux mêmes devant vos
nombreux téléspectateurs est à 2 puis
sol un les chers camarades et je suis
heureux et ému d'être là car vous le
savez j'aime adresse aux travailleurs
est renvoyée en format yeahs aux masses
populaires
on craint laborieuse lit de l'autre côté
ah oui et pour défendre les intérêts
sont dame en les grands intérêts de tous
contre la droite à giscard d'estaing qui
était financée par les grands trice
l'international noces et les grandes
sociétés multinationales au vrai j'ai
beaucoup ri sachez le oui parce que
drucker encore eût-il fallu que vous le
souci et j'ai beaucoup lit génie les
élèves du grand inspirateur du parti pc
pierre cardin calme axe qui habille le
capitalisme c'est l'exploitation de l'or
parlons bas soyez rassurés de richert
oui le socialiste exactement confrères
ball messieurs marché vis à vis je vous
ai amené un petit cadeau oui d'accord
oui c'est tony ouvrit le ça me fait
plaisir que c'est pas une bombe à
retardement vous inquiétez pas non c'est
le stand de tir à la fête de l'huma
était prêt visiter s'ils en avaient mis
un boeing de korean air lines a et celui
qui tirait dans le mille gagner à la
carte du parti si vous savez ce que
c'est c'est mon emblème c'est un peu
comme mon cerveau ces noix de coco mais
pour un coco à la noix comme vous c'est
dur
dehors et c'est mou dedans thierry le
luron